[موسيقى]
قلب يدق مشاعر صاحبه تتدفق وحيات اخرى
يعيشها الذين يقعون في الحب غارقين في
لذته التي لا تنتهي
باعماله والمه يبقى الحب احد اجمل الاشياء
في حياتنا لكن مهلا ما هو الحب وكيف ياتي
وما هي العلاقات التي تنطوي تحت هذا
الاحساس الذي نعتبره حبا حقيقيا
[موسيقى]
السر الكبير في الاكسيتوسين او ما يعرفوا
بهرمون الحب فهو صاحب الكلمه العليا بين
ثنائيات العاطفيه سواء كان بين المحبين
التقليديين من العشاق او بين الام
وابنائها
فهو المحرك الفعال في تاجج المشاعر
والمانح السحري لاكسير العشق الازلي لمن
جمعتهم الاقدار ليكون عشاقا
هذا ما كنا نعرفه عن هذا الهرمون من خلال
دراسات سابقه لكن دراسه جديده اجريت حديثا
على فئران البراري المعروفه بعلاقاتها
الاجتماعيه والعاطفيه والتي تشبه الى حد
كبير حياتنا الاجتماعيه كبشر تنفي الامر
في جملته وتقول انه رغم ازاله مستقبلات
الحب من هذه الفئران الا انها بقيت قادره
على بناء علاقات قويه كثينائيات وبقيه
الامهات تعتني بصغارها
الدراسه التي اجريت في جامعه كاليفورنيا
تفتح الباب على مسرعيه امام البحث في
العوامل الوراثيه التي تتحكم في السلوك
الاجتماعي والعاطفي كاشفه ان الاكستوسين
ليس سوى واحد من عده عوامل تنظم هذه
السلوكيات المعقده يبقى الحب سرا كبيرا في
قلوبنا وعقولنا سر قادر على ان يغير
حياتنا للافضل ان كان في محله وللاسوا ان
جاء في غيره مكانه